ya hemos montado todo lo necesario para
expresar esta integral de superficie que
es la parte derecha del teorema de
stocks y que escribimos completo aquí
ahora podemos expresar esto como un
integral doble sobre el dominio de los
parámetros que nos importan esto es lo
que haremos en este vídeo lo que haremos
en los siguientes será hacer lo mismo
pero con esta expresión de la izquierda
usando el teorema de greene y veremos
que obtenemos las mismas expresiones que
del lado derecho y así demostraremos que
el teorema de 'stocks' es cierto al
menos para esta clase especial de
superficies con la que empezamos aquí
pero en realidad este teorema es mucho
más general entonces vamos a intentar
hacer eso ahora vamos a escribir la
integral de superficie de quien del
rotacional de f
esto es la parte derecha del teorema
stoxx punto de ese punto de s
entonces si nos damos cuenta el
rotacional ya lo habíamos encontrado de
este lado aquí está el rotacional y el
de ese ya lo tenemos acá
esto es de s es igual a todo esto ok y
esto y multiplicado por una diferencial
de área entonces aquí está la de s
simplemente hay que hacer producto punto
con el rotacional entonces vamos a ir
haciendo esto porque esto se convierte
en una integral doble sobre el dominio r
que quien es el dominio r pues el
dominio r es justamente este donde
estamos moviéndonos sobre los parámetros
entonces es la integral doble sobre el
dominio r pero ahí se vea absolutamente
todo lo que necesitamos de quién
bueno pues tenemos que multiplicar las
coordenadas en y entonces tenemos menos
zx con ere y menos cruceta entonces el
menos lo que va a hacer con esta resta
es que cambien
digamos que estos dos los pueda
intercambiar en esta resta y simplemente
me va a quedar zx que multiplica a q
zeta - xerez y ok esta es la parte en la
coordenada i
ahora vamos a ver en la en la coordenada
j tenemos menos detalle que con este
menos de aquí se hace se cancelan y
multiplica simplemente a este entonces
tendremos más detalle que multiplica a r
x menos p z y ahora la última parte es
la más sencilla es la más sencilla
porque aquí acá no tiene no tiene una
función bueno esencialmente es la
constante 1 entonces uno va a
multiplicar a esta parte vamos a hacerlo
con ese mismo color entonces esto será
simplemente sumar q x menos
correcto entonces ya que ya tenemos esto
entonces ya hemos acabado expresamos la
integral de superficie como una integral
doble en el dominio de los parámetros
que nuevamente pues aquí está este es el
ere el dominio de los parámetros
correcto entonces lo que haremos en los
próximos vídeos será hacer lo mismo
usando el teorema de greene y veremos
que obtenemos exactamente el mismo valor